hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to oh hell
yeah I fuckin love Tom and Jerry with
their one destruction comedic timing and
hilarious sound effects this is the
original captain Mouse team have
perfected the art of cartoon violence
I'm such a fuckin dork I actually went
out and got the DVD collections of these
cartoons you know what I found out I'm
not the one who regards on this comic
Legends there's directors historians and
even comedy stars like Whoopi Goldberg
and MADtv cast members who all see Tom
and Jerry as comedic move with the
comedy team so legendary you think
Hollywood will put some real time and
effort into their first feature-length
film together they do not instead we've
got Tom and Jerry the movie's a 1992
film about what else Tom and Jerry but
now wait a minute the time of Jerry
cartoon is about seven minutes long with
just slapstick and silent humor how can
you possibly make an hour-and-a-half
movie out of this well let's take a look
in the opening credits we see Tom and
Jerry doing what they do best chasing
each other and here's our first problem
boys actors Tom and Jerry had little to
no voice actors in their cartoons but
hey maybe the slapstick will be funny
even the slapstick is wrong I mean this
is Tom Hale and this is the movies
god that's not nearly as funny and look
at this when Tom gets cut in half in the
cartoon it's humorous when Tom gets cut
in the movie man to show blood in this
what are they fucking psychos yeah and
here's a real joke creative consultant
joseph barbera let me say just went up
to him every day and ask is this
destroying your creation is this nothing
like your original vision yes good so
the film begins with Tom's owners moving
away the Tom accidentally gets flung out
the car is forced to stay at home it
turns out the youngers move just in time
as their house is being bulldozed to the
ground Tom and Jerry it's gay but are
left without a home so the two of them
have to roam the streets looking for
food and shelter these are the only good
parts of the movie where Tom and Jerry
tried to decide whether they should help
each other out or not and all without
any dialogue who's even acute in joke
with a restaurant called Bill and Joe's
obviously referencing Bill Hanna joseph
barbera the show's creators but it all
goes downhill when they meet this
singing gay dog is obnoxiously fleeting
Frankie
instead of being pals yeah fighting like
a cat and a mouse they gotta learn to be
pals or they ain't gonna make it out
here
it's like Peter Falk and George Carlin
secret love child except a dog the name
is Bugsy
what's yours Tom I'm Jerry
what the hell did they just talk des Tom
and Jerry one of the most famous silent
duo's of all time just speak to each
other no no no no no no it's gotta be a
mistake I gotta be hearing things I'm
gonna just go ahead and eat my customary
three pound watermelon and drink my
traditional pitcher of sangria both at
the same time while I confirm how wrong
it was about this ridiculous
misunderstanding what do you think I am
a dummy you said it
holy crap they actually talked the
apocalypse has finally begun Pixar
learning how to fly
Satan is skating his way to work and I'm
pretty sure that I just became a
monkey's uncle
unbelievable I mean just unbelievable
the one mole that you never break and
they broke it in the first 10 minutes I
mean isn't it like one of the ten
Commandments or something thou should
not live that should not covet thy
neighbor's wife Tom and Jerry don't talk
but wait it gets worse not only can they
talk but they can also sing we to where
Fred's to the end hate me my friend
you'll never find two other guys
compatible let's wait it gets worse not
only do they like this thing they have
to sing about how they don't like
chasing each other and how they enjoy
being friends
[Music]
France today
[Applause]
[Music]
my god Tom and Jerry are dead alas poor
Tom and Jerry I knew them viewing
audience to fellows of Infinite Jest of
most excellent fancy
they have borne me on many hilarious
antics a thousand times and now how
abhorred in my imagination it is my
Gorge rings added whatever the hell that
means here hung those lips that have
been mangled I know not how oft there be
no screams now you're torn lineage
[Music]
it was set up bowling pins that were
want to set children and adults on a
roar not one now to mock your ethics
Westeros fallen now get you to Hollywood
chamber and tell them let them stop this
douchebaggery that shuts and terrorizes
those with most excellent humor and show
them what makes such great
laughter so great make them laugh at
[Music]
should focus okay so after Tom and Jerry
become friends punsie is taken away
thank God buy a pair of Mexican wrestler
dog catchers so Tom and Jerry set off on
their own while running into a strange
gang of alley cat liked to do nothing
more than to sing another song oh come
on I already have one song kind of nuts
off my child but I don't need another
look at this it's like what's like pussy
I mean how can anyone find this
entertaining it's just torture why do we
care about nice why do we care about
sleaze oh yeah I'm gonna be coming that
tune all week so after they escape the
singing cat game guy did I really just
say that they come across another shadow
lurking in the alleyways who the hell is
this I'm Robyn Starling I'm afraid you
don't have a home anymore I'm sorry um
we're trying to shoot a movie here is
there any chance you can just count
bosey along yeah I'm an orphan my mother
died when I was a baby sucks um you know
we have a lot of shooting to do and that
dancing about Tom and Jerry I'm sure
it's gonna be very funny once it comes
out but you're kind of in the way right
now so if you could just you know can't
get out of the way that'd be great yeah
was all he's calling me
orphan she even stole my lock and threw
it out the window but I climbed out and
found it you're really not gonna leave
until we make a movie about you ha ha ha
okay all right right here
all right Tom and Jerry the movie is now
about a little orphan who's trying to
find her father
Indiana Jones while her evil odds and
lawyer goes searching for her because
apparently she's worth a lot of money oh
and there's a cat and mouse in there
somewhere but that that's on point so
yeah you're probably thinking what the
hell does this have to do with Tom and
Jerry well I guess the writers felt that
the story needed a little bit more
conflict because you know Tom and Jerry
didn't have any conflict whatsoever so
after talking under Exposition bridge
Tom Jerry and Robin decided
back to her aunt's house because they
think you're a band roof over their
heads is better than no work at all I
never thought anyone could depict an
actual representation of the giant
purple people eater but there's anything
that comes close its Robins aunt who
seems to be consumed by one thing we've
got to have my name Oh sounds like the
producers of this movie so they talk
about what they're gonna do with Robin
and oh no please not another one I'll do
anything I'll do your taxes I'll shave
your back I'll prostitute myself for
money just please not another one these
fucking songs music that's disgusting so
you might be asking yourself is there
any slapstick in this movie well there's
a fetch dog on a skateboard who seems to
pester Tom and Jerry as they try to eat
oh yeah and he sounds like Gollum but
again why isn't it Tom and Jerry doing
all that slapstick I don't give a shit
about the dog I'm just praying they put
them to sleep by the end of the movie
that goes double for me after making a
mess of the place robin's aunt decides
to scent on the jury to a person who
takes care of pets named dr. Apple
cheeks by the way have you noticed the
strange names in this movie dr. Apple
cheeks aunt Figg mr. lick boot these are
something more like abstract fetishes so
it turns out dr. Apple treats holds
which pets ransom and gives them back to
their owners for outrageous amounts of
money how do I know this because he
sings about it of course so while in the
pet prison kids who they bump into no
not him you killed Tommy jury you've
turned them into friends that ruined the
franchise what so Tom and Jerry escape
and try to help Robin get reunited with
her father
Hey look it's Tom Sawyer and Huckleberry
Finn
I've been watching this movie too long
but a giant ship separates our heroes as
Robin wakes up in an unknown house oh my
god I'm in hell I finally happened
I've asked Anne heap to their mate you
are the lucky guest of captain kitty
oh yes and my first mate squawk he's
funny
no he's frightening so while Robin is
stuck watching captain kitty psychotic
episode she manages to tell him where
she's going have you been to Tibet I
don't know why don't you think about it
why does everybody have a song in there
somebody might say yes or no a Carnegie
Hall
so tomandjerry find Robin
but unfortunately captain pedophile is
holding her ransom for a million-dollar
reward that her on promised on top of
that doctor Apple cheeks here's about
the reward and wants to get her to but
unfortunately he was tossed out of the
car that he was in so he has to find
another form of transportation what the
hell was that about
was it gonna sexually assaulted I mean
what the hell so Tom and Jerry help
Robin escape as they get on a boat which
they of course know how to drive this
results in a wild goose chase as
everyone chases after Robin in order to
get the million dollar fortune so let me
clarify this for those of you who might
have missed it a cat and mouse are
driving a ship trying to save the
daughter of Indiana Jones while being
chased by a purple people eater a dog on
a skateboard a performing ship captain
his hand Puckett squawk two Mexican
wrestlers and a doctor riding an ice
cream cart ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the mindfuck
[Music]
so Robin gets to the cabin where she
thinks her dad is only to find the bad
guys are there waiting for her but a
lamp falls over and of course starts a
fire burning down the entire camp I
always love how one spark can set off a
house fire in like two seconds watch you
see it looks like all hope is gone for
our three heroes until it's Robin's
father Indiana Jones
[Music]
he rescues his daughter and leaves
tomandjerry to burn alive in the fire
wait what
[Music]
that's dark
don't cry Robin we'll find them or at
least what's left of their charred
remains
either way we're eating tonight oh of
course they're alive they survived
Thanksgiving dinners more frightening
than family
so rather than her father adopt the cat
Mouse and invite them to live in their
home where of course Tom and Jerry start
doing what they should have been doing
throughout this entire movie I love this
little circle here like yep that's what
it's all about but nope that's not what
this film is about I'll tell you exactly
what this film is about this film is
often the lowest form of shit it sucks
ass it sucks balls it sucks ass balls if
I wants to go back in time to tell the
Tom and Jerry of 50 years ago that they
would be making a film of this caliber
about them what do you think they'd have
to say about I'm trying not to I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to Java fuck alone of ass